every time I've had a company sale when
we sold bibo to twitch when we just sold
the milk Road you have been our we call
the deal Doula you help us you know go
through that labor process and come out
the other side with you know the happy
ending I guess
[Music]
Sully welcome to my first million uh
you're subbing in for for sampar today
and like every substitute teacher it's
always the best when they're there
um we
we're going to do a bunch of things
we're going to talk about some of your
the companies you started the companies
you've invested in things are you know
some ideas you have you were the first
ever episode of the podcast so if people
want to hear your life story that's the
place to go episode number one
um we've come a long way from there did
you think this is what would happen
uh I always knew the podcast was going
to be big and uh I think from the very
beginning you were like let's do bar
stool except for business and that's
what it's become and it's huge and I
actually think it's going to be way
bigger in a year than it is today like
three times the size a year from now
than I just die uh yeah I hope so that's
the uh that's the goal uh we did the
kind of Barstool thing except without
hiring anybody it was like okay we will
just be the jackasses and then like Let
it go from there
um all right so I got you sent me this
doc which is great because there's a
bunch of topics on here that I kind of
want to jump into you uh I guess we
should set the the the like groundwork
here so so I'll give you a very short
life story so people understand who you
are you um
you worked at a job for like a couple
years you did like the traditional path
you worked at Microsoft you quit you
decided to start your own company this
is right when the Facebook app platform
comes out so you start building like
silly Facebook apps that go viral so uh
think things like superlatives which was
um like which of your friends most
likely to do X and uh it would invite
those friends to like do it too and it
grew like crazy but it was like a silly
Facebook app so you didn't have to do
with it but you ended up selling it so
you got that was your kind of my first
million moment so you sell it
um you're how old at that time like 24
25 ish 26 maybe uh yeah 26 26. take that
and you go on the next big wave which is
uh mobile apps are gonna be a thing you
are creating games I think maybe first
on Facebook and then on the iPhone when
when the iPhone app store comes out
you're like oh this is going to be big
you create a company called tiny uh or
tinico and
um end up
somehow you raise money from Andreessen
Horowitz you're living the dream things
go south as the economics of that
business change and then you go all in
in this Hail Mary strategy which again
episode one for the whole story you go
all in on this Hail Mary strategy of
like we're gonna get the rights to
Family Guy and you end up somehow as a
startup that nobody's ever heard of
getting the rights to the license to to
make the Family Guy mobile game you did
it for Harry Potter and a couple other
big IP things sell that company
um
and then that I met you after that so I
met you kind of when you were selling
that thing we met at a dinner that Sam
was throwing because you were speaking
at hustlecon and immediately we hit it
off we were we made some big plans we
were like you know you were talking
about Tony Robbins I was like oh I'm a
Tony Robbins guy you're like really I
don't even know about Tony Robbins tell
me and I started gushing about my
experience there or whatever and I was
like yeah we should do that here in San
Francisco like let's do it tomorrow
morning let's have a yeah a power
session with people like us who are just
you know electric and uh yeah we were
like uh Tony Robbins is amazing nobody
is doing this um in this kind of modern
way let's put up some Facebook ads today
um
and then tomorrow let's have 50 people
in here and try our hand at like and
Tony Robbins for a day we did the thing
we spent 20 minutes being like this is
great this is a great idea this is this
is a no-brainer and we gotta keep
talking about how much is the no-brainer
how much it's uh since I am dunk we're
gonna do it we're using all these terms
never did it 10 years later we've still
never did it but we became good friends
along the way I still think it's a great
idea yeah it would be the most fun
weekend ever
yeah I think I still think we should do
it we uh but then we we kind of got uh I
guess from there you you did a couple
things so your brother started native
deodorant you can help him with that you
started another company which we don't
really talk too much about then I was
starting my e-commerce brand you have
helped me out a lot with that or kind of
a shareholder in that business
um and when we were every time I've had
a company sale when we sold bibo to
twitch when we just sold the milk Road
you have been our we call the deal Doula
you help us you know go through that
labor process and come out the other
side with you know the happy ending I
guess
um so that that's kind of like how our
interactions have been like on a
business side and then become great
friends uh since then so that's my intro
did I miss anything
um I love being the deal Doula by the
way uh when we sold tiny Co we had this
Banker named dick filipini and he uh ran
he was our Banker ran the transaction
for us and I told him that I loved what
he did so much that I just wanted to
work for him for free for six months
after this so I could see all of the
deals that he was doing and uh he did
not accept my offer and said no you you
can't do this dick is great he helped us
for free when because people was the
Bible deal was gonna be too small he
does bigger deals like I think like 100
million dollar plus type deals
um it was too small but he got on the
phone with me several times that the
process talked me off a ledge multiple
times when I was like I'm just gonna say
this he's like no well you should
probably just wait see what they say
um and his advice was basically just
like don't F this up you know son and he
was totally right he helped me a ton and
actually I still feel the guilt that I
didn't like send him a gift afterwards
texted you like a year later I was like
what's Dick's address I didn't send him
a gift can't believe I didn't and here I
am still four years later I have not
sent that gift dick I'm so sorry you
were so helpful
the deal another deal that dick did that
I thought was super interesting was he
sold App 11 to a Chinese company for uh
one billion dollars
and the Trump Administration blocked the
deal or the FTC blocked the deal and uh
instead of it being a billion dollar
sale the Chinese company invested 100
million dollars into App 11 and then a
couple years later app 11. so everyone I
thought would be devastated like the
founders were like we're gonna become so
rich overnight as we sell this company
for a billion bucks
transaction doesn't happen I assume
Founders are sad and upset
then a couple years later the company
goes public and at some point it was
worth 30 billion dollars as a publicly
traded company yeah so such an amazing
transaction to not have uh closed well
they got the best of both because they
whatever the company was putting I think
it was 1.6 was the original 1.416 was
the original purchase price and they
were going to put in a few hundred
million dollars to own 70 or 80 of it
and then instead it was like the year
went by nothing happens and so with that
anxiety came this big payoff because the
business grew like crazy in that time so
they're like hey okay same deal but now
you own like 20 or 30 percent and so
they got the money they got liquid on
that but they only had to give up a tiny
fraction and then they sold it and then
they went public
um you know later for for way more so
that turned out
you know pretty much as good as it could
go right like yeah
uh just had to wait a year
um speaking of kind of like Acquisitions
I gotta I have a milk Road related
question for you first which is
um you saw you saw both the Acquisitions
that I did uh from like sort of start to
end and I shared you know
it's like in high school when it's like
the boy texted me this should I have
replied this should I say this like no
no that looks too needy say that like
change the period to a comma and then
just you know cut that last line like
it's that level of help that that you
were doing with me
um what's your I've given kind of my
debrief of the acquisition I'm just
curious what's your uh what was your
takeaway or what was your what are some
nuggets that that you would you would
share from uh from watching that go down
um I love the deal structure that uh
milk Road ended up with which was a
bunch of cash up front and then
um a bunch of equity in the new company
where those two guys are wanting to
grind it out for years and build a giant
business and uh those guys in my head
you know some percentage of the work
that they do is just creating value for
you and Ben and that's awesome so I love
that deal structure uh
the in my head uh kind of having been
through this a couple times I feel like
a lot of the
um you know texts the Nuance of words
that you care about when you're trying
to sell your business the buyer doesn't
care about that much
um and it's more of a emotional thing
than a practical thing where
practically the buyer is like
I want to buy this business because of
the Strategic reason and the revenue and
the profit and a lot of the things that
um you can be squeamish about or
uncomfortable to say or not sure how to
say things I think a lot of that stuff
doesn't matter
one of the things that I learned
actually when I was trying to sell
tiniko was
um
we ran a sales process where I was
trying to sell the business and we
talked to a bunch of uh acquirers and we
got pretty far along with one
um and then the deal didn't happen uh
and then a year later we went and sold
the company
um successfully and the
um there was a bunch of stuff that I was
trying to keep close to the chest and I
was like oh people aren't going to want
to hear this people aren't going to want
to hear that and what was great about a
banker and some somebody like dick was
uh he was like no actually this isn't a
big deal just tell these guys this and
uh they're not going to care about that
so it took uh this kind of un discomfort
I had around like things I thought were
secrets that I needed to take to the
Grave with me and he just made me
comfortable telling them about right Sam
Sam did something for me in this process
I was selling the milk crowd I was like
yo any kind of tips or advice you've had
and when he sold the HubSpot he goes oh
on the same note he goes just do uh just
tell them up front all the shitty things
about your business that they that might
scare them away because guess what
they're gonna find those anyways when it
comes to due diligence and you're just
gonna be you know four weeks in or six
weeks in emotionally invested and it's
gonna get ugly later and they're gonna
feel like they just found some like you
know big wart on the deal at that point
in time
um and he goes just tell them all the
skeletons your closet now and be like
here's all the reasons you shouldn't buy
this company if these bother you you now
know them and you can decide for
yourself you know if that's a deal
breaker for you this was like not the
very first thing but shortly after like
we went to a dinner and everybody was
interested we hadn't even fully
negotiated the deal but I just said
they're like you know any questions you
guys have or you know any any concerns
I said well you know I want to make sure
like you fully understand this business
um and you know I've been through this a
couple times and I just I know like
um it's better to be fully transparent
so I said yo here's all I made a list of
the reasons why you know you shouldn't
buy this here's all the skeletons in our
closet and you can look at these today
and you could you could decide if this
is too um too concerning for you you
know let's talk through these now and we
did it and later after the deal was
closed we did a debrief and they they
basically this is how you know they're
smart they're like what could we have
done better in the acquisition process
like
um you know from your point of view and
we're we're asked the same amazing it's
like how is that for you uh was that
good for you it was good for me and it
was like we we told them uh they told
they gave me that feedback they were
like you know you said something at this
dinner where you were just like here's
all the ugly parts of our business and
like let me just tell you about them and
we could talk through them they go that
built so much trust because we didn't
know you very well and immediately we
were like oh okay we feel we felt at
ease and
um we felt like we could trust you guys
going forward and so that turned out to
be a big win and that's the exact
opposite my you know I think the
entrepreneur's instinct is hide that you
know as far put it behind your back you
know if they if they if they ask for it
you show them but like don't scare them
away and and in fact what you want to do
is like find out as quickly as possible
if there's a real match here or not and
use that as a tool to build trust versus
to build distrust by not disclosing it
up front
the other thing I've seen entrepreneurs
do that I I think is also kind of uh the
wrong Common Sense out there is uh when
you ask an entrepreneur if they want to
sell their business entrepreneurs are
told to say no I do not want to sell my
business and they expect that the buyer
is going to come over the top and say
even if you don't want to sell your
business we're super interested in
buying it
will do anything it takes uh please come
talk to us and in practice that's not at
all how it works uh oftentimes a buyer
is looking at a bunch of different
businesses to buy at that point in time
and so they'll reach out or talk to 10
different businesses five of them will
say no we're not for sale and they'll
say okay great we're knocking these five
off we're going to focus on the five
that have said yeah we are for sale
right
and so what's the way to say yes without
seeming desperate there or assuming too
too eager to sell because you don't want
to do that either I think the way I've
done it before is
um
one when I was ready to sell a business
I would uh
find somebody that I knew was interested
but wouldn't have a good offer and get
them to make an offer and then say cool
uh go that enables you to reach out to
other people and say hey we have an
offer to sell a business and we're
thinking about uh whether or not to do
that and you are somebody that we think
there's a great strategic fit with so we
thought to talk to you before we did
something else yeah
if they come inbound it's sort of like
um
you know we have had interest and
nothing you know nothing felt felt right
you know we really like our business
um
but you know we respect you guys and if
that's something you you know we'll
obviously be open to listening uh you
know we we owe ourselves that right and
so so you kind of you just say we like
our business we had interests it hasn't
we we didn't real nothing went too far
because we weren't very you know weren't
too keen on it but you know really like
you if you want to talk like we're open
to talking there's no you know that's
fine yeah um yeah I think that's a good
setup and uh I think buyers who are
experienced can kind of read between the
lines pretty quickly uh because what you
just said is like I'm wide open somebody
please ask me out for a date I'm ready
uh you know and I'll be a cheap date
exactly but like it's the signal it's
the signal that I'm interested without
like
um without begging you uh but it's like
to be clear I'm interested yeah yeah
it's terrific it's like looking at
somebody across the bar for and catching
their eyes
um their eyes for one second and then
smiling and looking away there was a
another meeting we won't talk we won't
name the name but you were a part of a
few of the meetings as we talked to
different people from milk road and it
was the first meeting with one of the
buyers and you you immediately called me
afterwards and you were like wow and
then you said uh there's this phrase a
fool in his money are easily parted and
you immediately sniffed out that this
person was
sort of an idiot
um and like you know would would be and
sure enough they made the by far the
largest offer
um and you know it turned out to be you
know they turned out to be not not
exactly who we didn't go with them
because that but of of the three or four
people that we talked to this was one of
them but you sniffed that out
immediately what what tipped that off
for you and uh what can you say without
getting us in too much trouble
um you know there's a lot of people who
are charlatans nowadays and uh they'll
often lead with a lot of like flattery
and not substance
um like it's very easy for me to tell
when somebody is like hey this is who I
am I've done X Y I started this company
I sold it I started this company it
didn't work out they're just like honest
about their resume and there isn't
tremendous amounts of puffery
that with a couple Google searches you
can be like actually that's all not true
right
you've said a lot of words but you
haven't said anything yet okay that is
uh you know either I'm not understanding
what you're trying to say or you have
nothing to say basically yeah that's
right and they don't lead with like
numbers and information they lead with
uh like flowery language that doesn't go
anywhere
so I'm curious
um what are some business ideas that uh
you think somebody could start that
would be successful either at the
smaller scale like I think this can be
you know like a clear business that'll
make a few million bucks and I just
think you know if somebody out there is
looking for a way to get Financial
Freedom this is a way to here's a big
idea somebody who is willing to grind
that out should go do this
um the big idea that I like the most
right now is
um Robin Hood for Real Estate
so uh you know Robin Hood makes it easy
to invest in the stock market
um and the way I thought about this is
I've got a ton of friends who are you
know in their 20s that work at Facebook
or Google and they make a ton of money
but uh what they do with it is they just
stick it in their uh bank account or in
a savings account or a CD
sometimes they'll invest in the stock
market
um
I think it's so hard to be able to
invest in real estate and if there was a
turnkey way through a mobile app to be
able to invest in real estate
uh I think that would be huge and I
think it's really different you you did
this um investment and and I followed
you uh in a company called jar in India
and so they make it super easy to invest
in gold in India and so you can invest
with a dollar or fifty dollars or five
thousand dollars and just by going
there's no choice like a one click it's
just if you believe that gold is a good
thing to invested we'll make it easy for
you to do that thing that you already
think is a good idea exactly and so it's
a one-click thing of like how much money
do I want to invest today and then uh
they the best way to do it is to kind of
set up a subscription where every month
you're like cool I'm buying 200 of gold
every month and 10 years from now it's
gonna be worth millions of dollars uh I
think the same should happen with real
estate there's a bunch of companies that
are like cadra and
um fundrise or crowd Street yeah
whatever those are like but you have to
look at the individual deals
you have to be they're targeted towards
um people like me who like investing in
real estate and who are sophisticated
about it and want to know what what the
cap rate is and the location and the
year of construction and all this stuff
um I think there should be a one-click
way to be able to go buy equity in
rental properties that generate income
and uh it should be marketed to people
in their 20s it should be marketed
through Facebook it should be set up so
that ever you basically log in and are
like cool you want to invest in real
estate how much do you want to invest
every month 200 great 200 is now
happening in real estate you're now
investing 200 in real estate every month
and boom it doesn't ACH from your
account every month
on on the customer side and invest in
that real estate and the income that's
gets generated goes back and reinvests
in more real estate
and that's it and so it shows uh this is
how much you've invested so far and
here's how much it's worth boom okay
love it give me more what else you got
uh what else do you got hey hey whoa
whoa whoa what's going on here this is
uh you're the you're the guest of otter
here I got uh I'm doping ideas every
week here I'll give you one that like I
think is
I'll give you one that I get asked a lot
which is not actually what's a big idea
but what's the easiest way to get to
like a million dollars
um and I always think that like the
easiest way to get to a million dollars
if I need to get to a million dollars
right now here's here's what I would do
I would
um I would create an agency that's going
to Target a really specific part of a
business that makes money already and
just figure out how to make more of it
so for example
email marketing for uh e-commerce brands
or conversion rate optimization cro for
for companies so you basically say hey
visitors come to your site we can help
you convert more of that traffic into
sales and I think there's such an easy
play where you basically just create
content so you create content that
basically just says like
here's the before and here's the after
look I changed these three things
because I call this my you know my hot
cold hot method and um we boost a
revenue by 32 percent by the way if you
want somebody to boost your Revenue by
32 work with me and I think that this is
like a such a bootstrapable easy way to
get to 100K a month in Revenue right
like you get 10 clients paying you 10K a
month it is not hard to get 10 customers
to pay you 10K a month when it's
um a part of their business that's
already gonna produce like already
producing hundreds of thousands or if
not millions of dollars of Revenue and
you're going to provide you know the
turnkey service so you take it off you
take the headache off their plate but
you do it better than they're doing it
because you're you get seen as a thought
Leader by putting out like 10 of these
case studies and this happens all the
time with ad agencies email agencies
conversion rate optimization agencies
but you can do this with anything you
could do this with site speed you could
do this with like any number of things
so I would just go and you could start
with start at zero and become a quote
unquote thought leader expert just by
publishing like very simple before and
after like kind of case studies
um and you start by not even having a
client you say hey if I was this brand
here's what I would do look when they do
this it sucks uh you know they this is a
dead end for them or you know they
should steal this good idea from this
other company and so you could put
together case studies without even
having clients and so to me this is like
the easiest like if you are willing to
work hard and you feel stuck at a job
that maybe pays you 100K a year and
you're looking how do I go from 100K to
900k how do I get from 100K to you know
750k a year this is the like all all it
takes is hustle uh approach to that side
of the type of business and then those
businesses can be sold so like your job
you can't be you can't sell your job
right like if I write a book I might
write that that might be the title you
can't sell your job just like my one
line case for why you should start a
business instead of have a job and if
you get a business like this to
900k and you know 60 profit you could
sell that agency or that Consulting
business for maybe two or three times
you know ebitda and so you could sell
that you could make
600 to 800k a year and then sell it for
two or three million
um you know after a couple years and so
that's a very easy Pathway to Financial
Freedom easy meeting it's simple not not
that it's no effort but easy that like
anybody can do it it doesn't take being
the genius with the one idea who beats
all the competitors in the space
yeah I totally agree with that I think
there's a bunch of other examples in my
head like
um just setting up a Facebook pixel and
doing in a way that's actually optimized
um and perfect and following all the
Facebook guidelines I think that's super
hard and I think there should be some
guy who's like I'm the expert at this
right
um and I take care of that for you and I
gave a brand of e-commerce but like you
can also do this for just hey every
legal practice every dentist you need
websites I make websites for dentists
right so it doesn't even need to be like
you're the best at doing growth for d2c
Brands it could be like hey in
Minneapolis Minnesota I make the best
websites for restaurants in Minneapolis
Minnesota or legal practices whatever
and just through cold email or you know
some combination called email LinkedIn
referrals you can like get 10 customers
to pay 10K a month yeah I think you
could pick any of these um big sectors
of the economy like accounting law
medicine Dental
um I think Senior Living would be like
whatever you know yeah yeah and I'm just
gonna go and build a online thing that
um makes their life easier through
marketing to them making it easy to make
a website uh it's insane how many of
those old world businesses are still
like don't have a good website right
don't do any Google ads
um
our friend Nick Huber does this thing
where he's like he basically has a
Playbook to make a self storage unit run
better and so his thing is like I'll buy
it at some multiple but I know I can run
it at 30 more efficiently or 40 more
efficiently so I'm getting value I know
within nine months I have a turnkey
process to make this thing generate 30
or 40 more you better
and so he does that buying the
properties but you could also just take
that Playbook and say hey Self Storage
owner I will do this for you I'll do it
risk-free for you meaning you pay me
nothing unless I deliver this outcome if
I increase your Revenue by 30 or your
your net profit by 30 that would be you
know that would be great right and
here's my playbook I do these three
things you would agree that you're not
doing those three things today very well
right okay fantastic how about I deliver
those to you risk-free and when I do I
get to keep you know half the value for
the first year and then it drops down to
10 after that and you can do this for
Senior Living you could do this for Self
Storage you could do this for any
business that's like out there once you
find a good like whatever best practices
this is what Alex hermosi did with his
gym launch thing who's like hey Jim
owner you want more customers like he
used to own his own gym developed best
practices and then realized the the
value was not in his gym being around
with best practices but taking the best
practice and selling it to all gym
owners and so that's what he that's what
he did and I think you could do that
with like pretty much any any Niche
business
what do you think about Niche content
creators and kind of trying to build the
same thing by creating content in a
specific Niche like
um
you know eco-friendly sustainable
products that kind of thing so what
would somebody do there so I'm a I'm a
content creator what am I doing there in
this example
um making YouTube videos Instagram video
Instagram reels and tick tocks about
um that content for the business to
marketing two business owners as like
hey business owner here's what you
should do or two no not to business
owners to Consumers just being like this
is how I live a sustainable lifestyle
um kind of pick anything that you're
passionate about and make a bunch of
YouTube videos about it or content about
it and I think that can be a big
business like you know Doug demiro with
cars right
um see I I don't like those as much
because I a I think it's a good thing to
do because good things come of it I
don't think they're very reliable at
creating successful businesses most
content creators don't make successful
businesses right so if you just look
empirically at the numbers you're just
like okay of the two billion twitch
streamers and of the 10 million
YouTubers like Who's Making Over 10K a
year and the numbers like astronomically
small
um and so you know the problem with
those is that everybody wants to do that
and there's not a clear way to like get
the value out it is good to do because
you will learn you'll become good at
content you'll meet cool people it'll
lead you to the thing most likely but
it's not usually directly the thing
um when it's consumer facing if it's
business facing I think it's pretty easy
then to say oh yeah I Market to the
owners of self storage units I create
the best content for them
you know you could go that's what Nick
Sharma did right Nick charmer is like
hey I'm gonna write the best newsletter
for a e-commerce store owner and I'm
just going to put together awesome
information case studies deals whatever
for them and like that's not for the
consumer it's for the business owner and
he created you know what what should be
like a five to ten million dollar a year
business when it's fully mature
um
doing just that and I think you could do
that for basically the owner of any
business construction businesses
you know whatever
any you know doctors lawyers whoever any
any type of business if you if you focus
on that you you get good at doing that
so I think that one I like I don't like
the consumer-facing one as much because
I think the numbers would show that they
don't make very much money the way that
they currently do them and like you know
I have this problem too where it's like
um what's the most competitive thing is
like being like a content creator like
you know what what are most people doing
from like you know even like a 12 year
old can do it and I have this problem
myself where I'm like oh I want to
create a bunch of YouTube content and
then I'm like
man this you know I'm competing with
every 15 year old in America
and they're better and faster to have
more time and have nothing to lose and
are willing to do way crazier stuff like
wow that this might be the wrong game to
compete in and I you know I'm still
trying to square that for myself like is
this the right game or the wrong game to
even compete in
um I could have said that about podcasts
in general too right so like you know
some of the best things I've done have
been like in that category and it worked
out just fine
um but it does feel a little strange
it's like against my own business advice
to like don't compete in the thing that
everybody is trying to do because most
likely you know you're just playing game
the game on hard mode
yeah the way I've seen it done well is
like um there's this guy who's a realtor
in LA and
um you know Small Time realtor and he
started making these YouTube videos that
were walking through Mansions yeah he's
great uh yeah and so he just like made
10 of them and were like was like this
is fun and then he got access to more
and more uh places and just made really
high-end video walkthroughs of La
mansions and you know his job was
already to be a realtor so he was doing
this as a way to get new clients in LA
and then um
as he did more and more it became a
business of its own and he stopped being
a realtor and now will fly around the
world uh because people will be like I'm
trying to sell this house make a video
of it and I'll go make a video and a
million people will watch it in three
days because he's got so many YouTube
subscribers so I think where you're
combining it with like a profession that
you already have it probably is a good
fit like there's some guy who's
um SMB acquisition attorney on Twitter
and so it's just a great way for him to
get lead gen
um yeah new customers well I also think
like um
I don't know if there's a good thing or
a bad thing but it's that 30s age thing
where it's like
I used to think about a business and
only look up like wow the skyscrapers
are huge in this field I'm I too am
going to build a skyscraper and now I'm
like cool before I do that let me just
go quickly look at the graveyard of
people who have tried to do this and
like when I was in my 20s there was no
graveyard I didn't think about the
graveyard I'm like music startup love it
everybody loves music right like what
could go wrong yeah and then when you're
in your 30s you're like don't say social
networks start up let's see yeah I did
social networks for like seven years or
six years uh of my 20s because it was
like the skyscraper was so attractive
and like there is some beauty of just
doing it not even paying attention to
the graveyard like I think
the people who win will just do that and
it'll work and their success formula was
like yeah I didn't worry about the
graveyard why would I do that
um but as I got older I was like man you
know what's more fun than trying to
build a social network like winning is
really fun and so like let me just make
sure that whatever I'm doing like the
odds are not like 99.9 chance of failure
um like yeah that's because and if I'm
gonna do it okay I'll go in Eyes Wide
Open I'm gonna look at the graveyard and
say I'm still gonna do this that's kind
of what happened with the podcast it's
like you know what I'm still gonna do
this even though I know that most
podcasts nobody ever listens to
um whereas before I did not even pay
attention to that and I didn't you know
but I don't know if that's a net
positive it might be a net negative
actually in terms of like how uh the you
know the the the strength of that kind
of like the ignorance
yeah there's this guy Bobby kodek who's
the CEO of Activision and
um he's like I can be CEO of anything I
could be CEO of a toilet company or CEO
of Campbell Soup the thing that matters
to him is success and momentum and you
know there's so many people who are like
you're the CEO of a games company that's
what I my entire life would be made if I
could just be that and he's just like
success is what matters more than
anything else and I'm kind of closer to
that as I've gotten older where I'm like
um success is the thing that brings me
joy more than the specific category or
product that I work on the thing that I
think you've done
um really well Sean is you've seen
friends who will have a successful
business and you're like let me just
clone this business in a different
category like you know you did that with
Sam and um the hustle with milk Road and
then uh you saw an e-commerce business
with Ramon and the way that he was doing
it and you're like I could do this too
um so I think that's a really good way
to to do it that's like kind of
underrated uh and most people don't do
where they're like I see this person as
successful
um I'm just going to do the exact same
Playbook but in a different product
category or different sector yeah I call
it having a blueprint like if I don't
see that there is a blueprint of success
in a category and that it is
replicatable like okay I can look at how
the guy started Snapchat but if but that
doesn't seem very like yeah I can't
replicate that and so but when I saw in
e-commerce or I saw oh the newsletter
business I thought okay I'm not saying
this is easy but I like I understand
this this is simple enough for my dumb
brain to get how a business like this
works what is the cost what is the
where's the revenue come from where does
the growth come from got it
um did they have some unfair Advantage
did they did they start at the right
time and that there's now is like you
know not the right time or whatever I
try to just figure that out but if
there's a and so now with new things I
just look for that like first we're
gonna go searching for a blueprint I'm
gonna talk to people until I find a
blueprint like okay I wanna uh buy
companies cool Andrew Wilkinson is a
good blueprint what does he do how does
it work and then do I want to like do I
believe that I could replicate that in
my own way in my own sector or my own
style
um and if I don't see a blueprint I
don't really get that excited at this
point because I'm like why would I do it
without a blueprint when I can do it
with personally I'm like that or the
same thing if I'm gonna do it without a
blueprint
all right that's cool but I'm gonna make
the announcement hey I'm choosing to do
this without the blueprint and I got to
go in Eyes Wide Open on that so like all
of my rules I break all the time but I
say them and I do them because I'm like
I'm cool violating this rule but I just
I'm not gonna do it sometimes I'm not
gonna do it blindly I'm gonna do it
knowingly and I'm gonna make that trade
you know knowing exactly what I'm
trading off by making this decision
versus uh you know how I you know used
to do it where I didn't really
understand even know what I was looking
for
um you know when it came to that I want
to finish with some rapid fire can I do
some some quick ones and then I just
want you to say your reaction to this
okay so I'm gonna this first category is
things you've told me that I thought
were funny and I want you just like
react or elaborate sort of like explain
this tweet
um I don't know what the hell mental
models are I used to think I was dumb
for not knowing what mental models are
now I think everybody else is dumb for
thinking about the model some version of
that yeah that's right
um in Silicon Valley it's so in Vogue to
be like Oh I'm applying the you know
this cognitive bias theorem to the
situation
um and
you know everyone in Silicon Valley
that's smart talks like that and so I
was just like why do I when I see
something I don't see it in that same
way and I just thought I was an idiot
um and I always solve a problem like
from scratch like Tabla Raza like it's
the first time I've seen it and I just
like that way of doing it so I gave up
trying to find mental models
um all right another one you started
your first two businesses on what I'll
call waves so like the Facebook app
platform I think launched the same day
you like had quit your job and were like
what can I do next let me just do this
um you saw the announcement you're like
I'll just do that I have nothing to lose
um same thing with the mobile app store
launch I think you were one of the first
big iPhone games
um what are the waves today what would
22 year olds Julie be doing now
uh probably something in genetics or
um AI uh
yeah probably one of those two things
it's the biggest sectors okay what um
you uh seven years ago we were at dinner
and I was just asked you a question I
was like why haven't you were like I
want to build like a big company a
billion dollar company I was like why
haven't you done that already
uh you you're so smart you're so great
why like what's what's gone wrong and
you said to me I don't think I
understood what a billion dollar company
was before
what did that mean
uh I think you need to have a certain
moat and uh
there's a bunch of things you need to
get right to build a billion dollar
company you need to have a big Market
you have a clear way of getting
customers that
um makes economic sense uh and you need
um a product that's really good uh so
even today I feel like I've got a very
clear path to be able to build you know
100 200 million dollar businesses but I
haven't quite figured out how to build a
billion dollar business outside of
taking uh five or ten 100 200 million
dollar businesses I think there's a
different code to build a billion dollar
business than a hundred million dollar
one excellent uh what would you do if
you were Mr Beast
I would start a y combinator for
creators and maximize the uh basically
find uh the next Kim Kardashian the next
Mr Beast and uh support them and own a
piece of them and be a king maker where
I'm making other kings
um
you did a lot of startup investing I
think you've pulled back some from
startup investing give me the uh
the the bullet point version of your
take on Startup investing
um I think startup investing
uh I think competing for deals sucks I
hate trying I find it very demeaning
trying to convince somebody to let me
invest fifty thousand dollars in their
round uh a friend of mine was raising
money and got a term sheet from
Andreessen Horowitz and Bill Gurley at
Benchmark and went with the Andries and
Horowitz term sheet and Bill Gurley was
so mad that
um he called the founder up and like
yelled at them for two hours and sent
them 15 angry emails and uh Bill Gurley
is one of the most successful people in
the industry and the fact that he still
has to do that made me be like this is a
industry with no moat I don't want to
like have to go
um kind of beg or try to twist people's
arms to let me invest in their startup
the other thing that's happened is
trying to turn
um
fifty thousand dollar investments into
two million dollars over a 10-year
period
um doesn't really do anything for me
anymore so my first startup investment
ever was 100K investment a company
called chart boost in 2011 or 2012 and
then the company sold in 2021 and I made
two million dollars so that was a
10-year time span
um
so I think having to wait 10 years to
get uh Cash Out is really annoying and
makes me like it a lot less I think the
valuations have also gone really crazy
um
and companies are so much more
competitive like uh there's a company
called Divi home that raised at a
billion dollar valuation and there's
four other Divi homes out there
um that are competitors to it so the
combination of high valuations and
increased competition makes it really
hard to make any money as an investor
and I've evolved from being interested
in kind of making these 50k checks into
trying to buy a majority interest or a
30 40 interest in businesses that have
revenue and uh profit or a path to
profit I think that's a better way to
invest for me because
I'll see money back and be able to take
that money and reinvest it in other new
businesses what's the biggest investment
Miss you've had and biggest hit you've
had
um biggest Miss was uh coinbase
my uh at tiny Co we had this guy who
worked for me named Adam merber he was
roommates with Fred the
um coinbase co-founder and so Brian
Armstrong and Fred
um were
fundraising for their series a they got
a term sheet from Andreessen Horowitz
and
um Benchmark and a bunch of other firms
and so they called me and said hey
should we go with Benchmark should we go
with entries and Horowitz uh you know we
a tiny cup raise money from injuries and
Horowitz Mark and recent was on the
board
and uh
I was like go with Andreessen Horowitz
here's what's awesome about them and
um on that call if I was like hey by the
way can I put in 25K into this round uh
I feel like they would have said yes and
that 25k at their IPO was worth 200
million dollars
I think it's probably did you not ask if
you didn't believe or you didn't ask
because you didn't think about it
I didn't ask because I didn't believe
that's the honest answer yeah crypto
Bitcoin these guys are building PayPal
for crypto and Bitcoin that's silly
that's just PayPal
um what about biggest hit biggest hit
well let me ask you you wrote something
on here you said could have invest in
Facebook stock I thought you I read
something that you had bought after you
sold your company that was on the
Facebook app platform you had bought
Facebook secondary shares did you do
that or or am I missing that
um I did this really stupid thing uh
that I'm still embarrassed of to this
day which is I uh signed a contract to
buy some Facebook stock like 150 000
worth
and
um
the stock price you know was private but
in the private Market the price went
down by 50 percent
and I called my father and was like oh
you know this happened to me and he was
like don't worry about it just buy it
and
um you'll be fine it'll go back up and
uh instead I didn't buy it
um they I think they might have sued me
and said hey you signed a contract to
buy this and then I said okay fine I did
and I paid them uh 75 000 to not buy it
versus 150k to buy it
yeah yeah it's 150 I could buy it so I
paid them 75k to not buy it and I was
gonna go buy
um some from somebody else who was
selling it and
um
they backed out so I didn't end up
buying it and then while I was uh buying
it from the other guy somebody else came
to me and was like hey um I've got
Facebook stock to sell too and so I
hooked up a friend of mine with that
Facebook stock and he bought 50k worth
of stock
and that 50k ended up being worth like
eight million dollars uh for him which
is kind of amazing
um
and uh I was actually raising a fund to
be like we're just gonna buy Facebook
yeah because that's what I read I after
we had very first met I was like who is
this guy I Googled you and I saw some
article where you had sold your app on
the your Facebook app and you were like
it was like what are you gonna do now
and you're like actually I think
Facebook is the good investment not like
my app and you're like I'm gonna just
buy like millions of dollars of Facebook
stock if I can
um and I was like wow this guy is super
aggressive and interesting like I what a
great in hindsight well this was now
many years later so I was like you know
wow that must have turned out amazing I
didn't I never asked you about it I
never knew the full story
yeah this was in 2008 during the great
financial crisis so everyone was running
away from everything and Facebook was
valued at two billion dollars in the
private Market at the time
um
and you know had an IPO and was unclear
when it would IPO
um was you know probably at a 100 or 200
million Maus something along those lines
um and actually I met this guy who's uh
in New York City and was like hey I'm
trying to buy this stock and he's like
that's a brilliant idea and I was like
yeah I'm trying to Mac you know get the
best price possible and he's like you
idiot don't worry about what price
you're getting just buy from everyone
who's selling it go buy it because this
price is so cheap that it doesn't matter
matter don't worry about whether it's 2
billion or 3 billion or 4 billion just
go buy buy it all and uh
I just kind of [__] it up yeah easier
said than done for sure when those
moments happen uh it's happening right
now in crypto it's like I know so many
people that were like ah I missed it I
wish I got in blah blah blah as it was
going up crashes back down to you know
eats at a thousand Bitcoin was at 16 000
you know like a month ago
and it's like hey you know if you did
want to buy like now would be a pretty
good time to buy probably and they're
like oh man this thing is who knows now
and they're the same people that three
years from now are gonna be like I wish
I had bought again and they're still
they're just never gonna buy there's
gonna constantly show inside and wish
that they were buying and never buy at
the times they should and always wish
they could buy at the times they
shouldn't
that's me right now because I've got
like 40 million dollars or 50 million
dollars in UST bills that like mature
every 30 days and
um I'm keeping them on in like short
term t-bills because I'm like I'm gonna
find some other investment whether
that's the S P 500 or something else
there will be other Investments and now
is the time to go buy them
um
the a couple months ago the S P 500 was
at like 3600 and that was my trigger to
go buy it and I was like ah it's gonna
go to 3 500. I'm gonna wait till 3 500.
it never hit 3 500. I am still sitting
on those T bills did not buy S P 500
yeah very very hard to do this sort of
thing but like uh maybe this is where
the mental model works the cognitive
bias or the whatever whatever bias this
is I got it uh you know there's someone
out there who knows all these biases and
they they're right I have all of them
actually my father is really good at
this and um you know I sold my first
startup and made a million bucks in
2008.
um he lived in Florida and was like all
the uh real estate prices here are at 25
cents on the dollar I'm gonna go buy it
and so he bought a house I sent him the
million dollars he went and bought a
house for 150 000 two weeks later that
same house was selling for seventy five
thousand dollars if it was me I this is
literally what I did I would have
freaked out and said [__] I don't know
what I'm doing I'm gonna stop this is
not working instead he bought another
house for seventy five thousand dollars
and he just kept buying houses
um
like for the next two years uh all the
way on the way down as the stock market
as the real estate prices
um bottomed out kept going down and then
even on the way back up as they were
increasing he would just keep buying
them and so as a result he owns our ways
of family now on something like a
hundred uh you know single family
rentals in Florida
and what's the line there between
degenerate Gambler because I've done
that too when I'm losing money and
playing poker or with blackjack or
whatever what's the line between
degenerate Gambler and genus maybe there
is no line maybe it's how the result
turns out yeah I think it's a result but
also it's the psychology going in where
you're like I know this is going to go
down I don't care because I I know I can
wait five years or ten years and this
will go back up right and he was like
this is below replacement costs so if
you were to build a new home right next
door that was the same home costume it
would cost you four times as much as I'm
paying for it right now so yeah amazing
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
you have a very honest LinkedIn and I
saw a guy who I think one-ups here and I
actually want to tell you about this
business in a second that's amazing so
Google this guy Justin Yoshimura
so Justin and then Yoshi m-u-r-a so I
want to read you this guy's LinkedIn he
goes I'm currently the founder founder
chairman and CEO of CSE Holdings one of
the dime a dozen quote-unquote unicorn
startups so already I'm like wow
startups dime a dozen I'm trying I've
been trying for 15 years to make a
unicorn he's like these are damn a dozen
and then he goes after being told that
nobody would ever hire me I quit the
bureaucracy and the negative negativity
of Palos Verdes high school so already
just like holding a grudge against his
high school to start a Marketplace for
unlocked cell phones anybody who sells
cell phones ringtones or any of that
[__] they're like the best they're a
great Hustlers so already you know bonus
points so he's got two points first
making fun of the fact that he owns he's
a CEO of a unicorn second heist dropped
out of high school and sold unlocked
cell phones he goes which was acquired
by Family office when I was 19 years old
more recently I started 500 friends of
marketing loyalty thing we merged with
whoever and eventually acquired by
whatever then he goes I Angel lost 50k
to 1 million in interesting companies
run by interesting people that he names
a bunch when he names the companies he
names the round he invested in another
key another key thing that only real
investors and honest people do
um which is that they you know you know
I invested in mucks in the seed round I
remember this one late stage right
versus what most people do is they'll go
by you know Airbnb shares in the public
market and call themselves an investor
in Airbnb right it's like we know we
know what you're doing here I've seen
big Venture funds do that too where
they're like oh this is a hot company we
want to invest in the secondary in the
series d a couple million bucks just to
be able to put on our website small
amount at any evaluation don't care I'm
just buying a logo basically yeah
um so then he goes
besides besides business and things I
shouldn't be discussing on LinkedIn I
love animals dogs many cats especially
Persian Himalayan dolphins whales and
names like 10 animals manatees Turtles
and he goes despite this I'm not a
vegetarian mainly because I lack
self-discipline however I do want to
clarify I don't eat any of the animals
above and I would judge you for doing so
especially considering that the
prevalent belief is that eating wild
animals at wet marks is what caused
covet oh my God where's this LinkedIn
profile going and then he goes I've been
included in many vanity lists such as
Forbes 30 to 30 Inc 500 whatever yeah 40
under 40 but thankfully I stopped
advertising these on my LinkedIn
headline when I was 19. after realized I
was being a douchebag for a formal bio
go to my Wikipedia so
do you know have you ever heard of this
company CSC generation it's very
interesting so what he did was he
started buying up
all these like kind of antiquated
Furniture companies so it's this it's
this kind of hush-hush thing but they
own Z Gallery which like half my house
is like from Z Gallery
um he owns uh what are the other ones
here one Kings Lane he Lo he owns Sur La
uh latable so he's bought like cereal
tablet for 89 million Z Gallery for 20
million one Kings Lane and then he
started making offers to buy I heard
about him because
um my our buddy I don't know if you know
metab but metab uh sent me this right he
goes this gotta be great for the Pod and
metabs like 100 signal to noise ratio if
he sends me something a book I've
instantly buy it so this was like
instantly just put it on the list do
research on this guy so this guy's 32
years old he's built basically like a
sort of like a billion-ish let's call it
a dollar Company Rolling these up and
what he's doing is he's making them more
like e-commerce and digitally like Savvy
uh so he'll close down half of the
retail locations that aren't performing
he'll get the e-commerce side to build
up he'll take all the customer data that
that they have and he's like dude they
they have like years of customer
purchasing data but it's in a machine
that's like 20 years old that they can't
even like literally extract and like put
into an email database or like find that
you know put it into Facebook ads or
anything like that so he's like we take
this he's like we built a system to buy
these companies and he's trying to build
like what constellation software did for
small SAS companies he's trying to do
that for large furniture companies he's
like he's like that's my model they
built a amazing intake engine to buy
like 30 30 software companies a year and
like unlock more value from them I'm
trying to do the same with Furniture
companies and this guy gives like no
interviews
um he's just this one guy and the reason
he's on people's radar now is because he
started making these wild public offers
at these old school Furniture companies
so he went to them privately he's like
I'd like to buy your company and they're
like
you know they're in Nebraska they're 65
years old they're like you know my
father's father built this table in this
furniture store like what are you
talking about and he's here's this 32
year old kid who lives in L.A and
they're like no we don't we don't want
your kind here basically so they don't
like his offer so he's like okay this is
getting me nowhere so he just started
releasing press releases saying I'd like
to buy this company for 20 or 30 over
the public you know share price right
now please respond board uh you have not
been productive you have not responded
to my offer in private you have not told
me a counteroffer you've said either yes
or no your shareholders deserve this
um publicly so he's publicly making
offers on these two public companies and
that's how he's like now on people's
radar because he was like pretty much
doing this under the radar before this
what do you think of this uh this guy
this idea
that's genius uh I love it because
there's just so much unlocked value in
these businesses and he's focused on a
specific
vertical Furniture I have no idea why
he's focused on that vertical but just
that kind of focus will allow him to be
able to take the same product sell it
across a lot of these different
retailers get crazy improvements in
margin by combining the scale of all of
these and the idea of doing it going
after publicly traded companies that are
like undervalued
so good and so he he said so they're
doing they're doing over a little over a
billion in Revenue now out of their
thing and he said he's targeting
Furniture because they're undervalued
they lag
um they're like kind of like uh they're
sort of like lagging and they they who
could benefit the most from like a
digital glow up he's like it's these
companies that are like basically not
participating in the right way in like
the digital world and the economy and
e-commerce and whatnot and so um he goes
a lot of these old school Furniture
companies have a ton of customer data
it's an old physical server in their
warehouse software's 30 40 years old the
company that made the software's out of
business you can't even like get them to
update it he goes
um I'm just trying to get it to be
modern we've built a platform and a
process to unlock the value of this
customer data I'm always a little a
little uh skeptical of that type of
claim but
um he goes I have I have no desire to
have my own brand
um because consolation software has no
brand they're just a 40 billion dollar
company that goes 33 a year 10 years ago
the stock price is 100 now it's 2 000.
they created a platform them to buy
these companies and unlock the value and
tuck them in they have the
infrastructure people in process they
created a machine to unlock value in
this category I don't think anybody's
done that in retail that's what we want
to become
wow uh first of all I just love the tone
with which he speaks and like the
humility and is just kind of like this
is what we're doing it's simple there's
no magic to it it's obvious in fact why
isn't somebody else doing this okay
nobody else's we'll do it and that's
kind of amazing so I bring this up for
two reasons one on the tone uh he
reminds me of you your LinkedIn is the
same way where you'll be like I invested
this company kind of got it was kind of
like a Yelp for this ish I don't know
these guys can explain it better and
like no no investor would write that on
there or you'd be like yeah I kind of
got acquired aquahari-ish I don't know
good outcome for the guys you know okay
for me
um you're very honest with like your
portfolio which I thought was good and
unique nobody writes on LinkedIn like
that LinkedIn is basically like you know
it's like those dog shows it's not like
owning a dog it's like those dog shows
if you watched a dog show you'd be like
is this what owning a dog is like if
you're like no that's nothing like what
owning a dog is like
um so I thought you like that you also
when I started my Ecom Biz you sent me a
one-line email I don't know if you
remember this you go
you go with my last business
we realized that we just have to do this
one thing differently than everybody
than like the current status quo and it
would work we didn't need magic it
didn't need like 10 genius things we
just needed we just had this one
fundamental thing what's the one thing
you're gonna do that's gonna make this
work
um and like you know that one question I
was like spinning for like a week
because I was like I don't know I don't
have a good answer to this question does
this mean my business is gonna fail uh
but this is a great question and I
stashed it in my great questions list I
thought okay I need to find that for
this business but also for every
business going forward what is the one
thing that needs to be true or like you
know is true about this uh do you
remember sending me that no not at all
but I think uh that sounds like the sort
of thing I would do it for some reason
it reminds me of um my first company I
started uh I started with a A friend of
mine from college
um and we sold the company and after we
sold the company we got into a fight and
uh he sent me this email that was like
50 reasons this company succeeded
despite your existence
and I was like ouch and so I went and
read it and uh you know he got to like
25 good reasons and then uh 26 he was
like you get the gist and for a little
while I've read that email
um like every day for like the first
year that I got it and then after that I
read it um like kind of once a year
every year to just be like what is it
that he said and what was the truth to
it
um
I don't know why it reminds me of that
but uh that was such a great
um great
email there was some truth to it enough
where I could kind of be like cool let
me just take this feedback and action it
in the future
um and
is also ironic in that
um you know he uh
he didn't he kind of gave up the startup
game kind of shortly after that man you
really broke him as a partner well he
actually tried to do a couple of their
startups and then I think um and I think
got into ycee and did a YC funded
startup
um
but I think it's you know the start of
game is a hard game and so he was just
like this this game isn't for me after
some number of years
um and the other thing that's crazy
actually is uh so you know I started
that company then I started tiny Co and
we were raising our series a from
Andresen Horowitz and he found out and
um
he sent them an email saying you
shouldn't let this guy you shouldn't
invest in this guy call me and so they
called him and you know he was like
basically read that list of 50 things
and uh you know it almost killed the
kill the deal because they were like
yeah we're worried about investing in
this deal because of this
um
and uh it's funny because there's so
many things that
um
people uh there's so many things that
people will like admonish privately but
uh but kind of celebrate publicly like
Travis the Uber CEO when he heard that
some company some VC fund was investing
and left he stopped what he was doing he
drove down to that VC firm and said here
are all the reasons you shouldn't invest
in Lyft right and that seems crazy uh
but because he was successful brilliant
and uh there were a couple other things
with like Mark Pincus and Zynga where he
did the same thing
so um it was just a funny experience
going through that with him and the kind
of recent Horowitz series a and uh it's
funny now because somehow uh 10 years
later we're uh great friends again and
uh you know he got married and I was
like the best man at his wedding
happy ending to this you um you also
have been talking about this kind of
like buy a public company thing so
because I'm like yo what's next for you
all right what do you what's the next
big swing what are you excited to do and
uh you've talked about this so let's
let's go into some of those that idea
because I don't think most people in the
startup game
think or talk about going and buying a
public company or or you know sort of a
hostile takeover or what have you uh
what's the idea here and why might you
do it
um yes I've been kind of trying to
figure out what to do next I think after
tiny Co I was like Wow startups are hard
I'm going to try to take it easy and uh
uh now gotten to a place where I'm like
cool let's do something big again
um and starting a new company from
scratch is really hard so I've just been
like is there a public company that I
can acquire
um where I don't go through that zero to
one phase that everybody loves but is
really difficult and go to a place where
something's already at a five or ten
and can I then take that and scale it as
an as a way of kind of running a
business
um so to me the perfect business out
there to acquire is this company that
was that's this is number one on my list
is a company that was a three billion
dollar that's currently a three billion
dollar company but in the private Market
was 10 billion dollars so it was worth
10 billion dollars before and now as a
public company it's worth three billion
dollars uh the company is Squarespace
is in their ads now
yeah Squarespace spends uh so much money
on these like podcast ads and uh you
hear about them everywhere on podcasts
or
um places that you wouldn't really you
don't see companies doing like direct
response advertising like I never see
them on Facebook but I always hear about
them on podcasts
and so the stock is down you know 50
since the IPO they're at this like kind
of 900 million Revenue run rate now uh
it's a subscription business with more
than 4 million subscribers
um
I'd love to buy it because I think it's
a great company that's super undervalued
uh it's not being run to maximize
profits so it's being run in a way that
um keeps it at break even so I think you
could run it to maximize profits get rid
of those podcast ads focus on Direct
response uh Facebook ads to get new
customers
in their in their spending
they do a ton of like uh
D non-direct response ads that are like
TV ads or podcast ads that I think are
great to have this like halo effect
around the brand but I don't think those
are the optimal way to maximize return
on ad spend right
and so they do I think 300 or 400
million of marketing spend so that's one
you could make that more efficient or
cut that down where what is the the
other is it like like you know like Elon
buys Twitter he fires half the staff
type of thing there's like a huge head
count or what else is like uh fat in
their system yeah I think they've got a
ton more people than they need and their
head count costs are like 225 million a
year and their headquarters in is in New
York City and I think you could just
cut that team materially and
um
you know get rid of the New York City
headquarters because it's super
expensive to be there
yeah Sam was talking about I remember
back in the day like uh one of the
earliest podcasts to talk about Casper
and he's like Casper you know how I knew
Casper's gonna fail they had like 150
employees in New York and it's like why
are you why are you hiring all these
people in New York you don't need these
people should be sitting in like you
know South Carolina
Omaha and like you know these other
places like why is your customer support
you know somebody making you know all
this money in in New York he's like
that's the first thing you got to do is
just get rid of New York and he was like
so adamant about it I was like his
number one rant and this is at a time
when Casper was still like
seen as like kind of like one of the
Rising Stars like now I think Jasper's
just kind of taking a beating in the in
the market and all that stuff
um I think it might have gone private
again
um because it yeah private could it
couldn't last publicly I guess but uh
but I remember that was his like number
one thing he was like I say no more I
don't need to read the p l uh I just saw
how many employees work in New York I
could tell you this business is
mismanaged from day one there's this
great Carl icon story where he buys a
business uh that makes like
um subway cars and uh they've got a huge
team in New York and a team somewhere in
Middle America and he goes the team in
New York and is like there's three
floors of them and some fancy Midtown
building and he's like so what do you
guys do and uh you know they show them
all these presentations for two days and
he's like okay I saw the presentation
and said what do you guys do and they're
like we just told you and so there he's
like all right let me go visit the guy
who runs the Middle America thing that
actually makes the railroad cars
and so he goes to visit them and he
hangs out with a guy and the guy's super
charming and at the end of the day he's
like so uh you know there are these guys
in New York what do they do for you uh
do you need them and he's like no those
guys don't do anything in fact I got
four guys that are just there to manage
those guys and all the questions that
they bother us with firewall yeah if you
get rid of those guys I uh think if the
business will continue to grow and uh
we'll be fine and so the next day he
goes back to New York and fires three
floors of people
it's like that scene in entourage where
Ari Gold just walks in with the
paintball gun and just starts blasting
everybody that's basically what like the
the New York uh the New York firing by
Carl Icahn yeah he tells this story with
such a smile and
um actually he tells it as like this was
pretty early in my career uh so it took
me like a couple months to do this if it
was now I would buy the company and fire
them like the next week
and so how does somebody actually do
this how do you go buy a three billion
dollar company because you're rich but
you're not three billion dollars to
spend on a company Rich so how does
somebody do this
yeah um I think three billion the three
billion dollar thing is probably too
much for my uh you know personal balance
sheet but the way you would go around
about it is just like the guy at CSC
generation is doing which is
um make a public offer it's the same way
Elon Musk did it uh you first make a
private offer then you make a public
offer you
um make sure that all your financing is
lined up when you do the public offer
and you know the way that the U.S stock
market works and
um shareholder rights laws work is a
board has to respond to that offer
and they have to have a really good
reason to not take it if if it's at a
material premium to the current stock
price
otherwise they're going to get sued out
the Wazoo by shareholders right
um
and so yeah that's kind of how you do it
okay so that's that's one way you
um let's do some of the other things
let's do so that's from big idea to
fun smaller ideas so you uh you were
telling me something like you helped
your buddy your I don't know high school
friend or college friend or something
like this sell their dental practice
what uh tell us teach me about that I
don't know anything about that yeah uh
this was a chance for me to be a deal
Doula so this a friend of mine called me
and was like hey I got a quick question
for you
um somebody I I started this dental
practice you know 10 years ago somebody
um came in to make an offer should I
take it and you know I thought it was
going to be one phone call it ended up
being like 60 hours of work with a bunch
of phone calls with him and and the
buyers of the business
um
and it was super cool to see the inside
of a dental practice and how uh the p l
looks and how a company gets acquired
like that so he has a dental practice
that's massively profitable that he runs
in a way where he's optimizing for his
lifestyle so he does seven figures in
ebitda has a 50 net margin all while
working three days a week and uh I was
just like oh my God what is he doing the
other days
he is making up new hobbies that uh he's
getting excited about like uh he's never
gone fishing before and he's like I got
all this time to kill because I don't
know all this gear now I have to learn
this Hobby
yeah so he'll go find a new hobby and
like buy the gear find somebody in town
who uh is good at that Hobby and go with
them so actually I hung out with him
um recently and he's like let's go
fishing I was like when did you take up
fishing he's like I got so much time
so he works three days a week and uh
he's not optimizing the business for
ebitda he has a big waiting list of
patients who want to become patients but
he doesn't have the time to see them he
has one dentist that works for him and a
bunch of dental hygienists
but none of that is being done in a way
where he's like optimizing for revenue
or Profit just optimizing for his
quality of life
so this private Equity Firm
um is doing a roll-up of all of these
dentists in that area and it's super
interesting how the private Equity so
they've got a company that's going
around and doing this roll-up of dental
practices the company is
um run has a CEO which is a dentist
super nice guy uh super well known in
the area and admired by admired and
liked by all of the other dentists in
the area so he's kind of like the
figurehead of the company
good cop
then they've got a CEO who is this
um hardened guy who's bought tons of
businesses and worked for a bunch of
private Equity firms and has an
experienced acquirer and you don't even
like talking to him after you know five
minutes and he's the bad cop so good cop
and bad cop go in and you know good cop
does all the Charming saying this is
going to be a great acquisition look at
how it's turned out for me bad cop
um does all of the numbers and
negotiating
so they bought this business and uh they
bought it with a really simple premise
they bought it for a 7x ebitda multiple
and they're like we're gonna go buy all
the dentists in this area that we can
and we'll sell it at a 15x ebitda
multiple because we'll get to a scale of
you know 20 30 million in ebitda
and that's just the valuation Arbitrage
right which is basically that small
ebitda businesses like let's say you're
doing a million or two million they'll
sell for 7x but if you had 20 million of
even in a business it'll get acquired by
a larger institution it's an easier buy
button to buy 20 million a a year of
ebitda for 15x that's that's and so all
you have to do is kind of like
accumulate roll up and and put this
together to get to that next stage of
buyer
yeah exactly right so that's one aspect
and then the other aspect is they were
like there's all these things that we
can do to increase revenue for this
guy's business one we're gonna add
another dentist eliminate the waiting
list anyone wants to see a dentist
they're going to be able to see a
dentist within a week they added another
dental hygienist chair so the dental
hygienist chair costs like ten thousand
dollars and
um my buddy uh just didn't go buy one
and uh kind of put a dental hygienist
there to increase dental hygiene Revenue
um they even told him that uh there's
all these things they can do to maximize
to increase the amount of money they get
from insurance companies so they were
like there's this one instrument
whenever you're doing a cleaning just
pick this instrument up you don't even
have to put it inside the mouth of the
patient just pick it up for a second and
then put it back down and then you can
claim at this higher Insurance code and
we're going to generate more Revenue
called me and was like you know is this
moral or is this immoral like can I go
back to these guys and say hey I don't
want to do this this doesn't seem right
he said as he's holding the tool up for
45 minutes just to see what happens
that's right uh and then because they
bought all these other Dental practices
in the area they're able to take one
dental practice and say oh
um you need braces or you need a root
canal or you need whatever uh oral
surgery procedure we're going to refer
you out to somebody and so they used to
he used to refer to people who are just
kind of third parties and now he gets to
refer to people that are in the network
already owned by the private Equity Firm
nice
yeah okay that's great so you see that
machine and you're like wow this is
amazing uh what's your kind of like big
takeaway from that experience because I
think most people wouldn't take the time
to go do that uh you did and I think you
probably got something out of it what
what was your big takeaways uh well I
thought it was amazing there was a win
for the private Equity Firm and just
being able to see the roll up strategy
and and how good it was for them up
front was awesome I also got to see it
from his perspective and from his
perspective it was also a huge win it
was an easy transaction he didn't shop
it around
um it was a way for him to retire and
become the richest person that he knows
he owned the real estate of the dental
practice so he got to keep the real
estate and now the choir pays him rent
every month for the real estate that he
owns and uh now he gets to go because he
was working three days a week which is a
lot he now gets to take month-long
vacations to Europe or Africa or
wherever he wants to go for fun with his
whole family
yeah that's amazing I also like the I'm
the richest guy I know that I think
that's a funny thing that actually does
happen in a bunch of like especially
smaller towns and uh like Niche things
it's like if you can make eight million
dollars or something like that you are
you you know you're done like you don't
need any more and you you feel like
there's a beauty in that like if you're
in Silicon Valley you could build a
billion dollar business and like you
might not get invited to the big boy
table still uh right because it's just
like everybody knows 50 people that are
more successful younger smarter and uh
you know more ambitious than them and so
there's just this never-ending you know
like race that you're on if you're in
Silicon Valley New York LA and that's
just not true in these other places and
I think there's some there's something
great about that yeah it's amazing the
only way to win the rat race is to opt
out of the Rat Race and uh he has opted
out and uh has thereby won the rat race
and it's so funny to compare my life to
his because
um I spent so much more time working and
uh
you know have made a bunch of money so
that maybe I don't need to work as hard
or at all uh and yet I continue to work
and he's like I'm chilling
and uh you've thought about that or no
it's like just not your nature
um I have one of my goals for 2023 is to
like take it a lot easier work wise and
spend a lot more time uh doing as many
fun things as possible like I'm in LA
right now they have this thing called
the Porsche Driving Experience uh so you
go and go with a bunch of friends uh
they've got Porsches and a racetrack and
you get in a Porsche and just drive it
around the racetrack as fast as you can
without killing yourself
when you know when we got back from the
weekend getaway that we did I gave a
debrief and I talked about this one
observation I had which was that at that
thing there was P we met people or we
were hanging out with people that were
of like four or five different life
phases so there was like
um you know uh you know Victor and Jude
are basically like you know 12 year olds
and their mindset was like yo wake up
it's time to play like they literally
woke us up with a boom Box by the window
just playing like you know Tiësto or
something like that and they're like
come on the pool's already warm and then
we can go to the sauna then we could
play golf then we could play with ball
we could play this and play that like
they were just and like from the moment
they woke up to the moment they went to
sleep they were like let's play so I was
like the you know 12 year olds and then
it was like the 20 year olds we met that
came over that night that were basically
like building the nft projects or doing
the like Tick Tock in The Tick Tock d2c
brand that was just taken off and they
were like
I don't know how to describe but they
were kind of like in that hustle of like
they kind of thought they had it all
figured out but they don't but they
don't realize that yet but that lets
them do some cool [__] because they
don't know what they don't know yet so
they were just like young stallions like
just you know full of exuberance and
didn't understand where the limitations
were or what the drawbacks were but
that's okay they'll run head first into
that wall when it comes but they're
having a good time doing it and then
there was like me band like we're like
in our 30s and it's like you know the 30
year olds were sort of like okay I'm I'm
you know I still have enough energy to
do things but I'm not dumb enough to
just do them blindly I don't have that
that great ignorance yet I I really like
kind of over analyze things almost and
so the whole time we were like trying to
think through our next project trying to
like sit down and map it out and pros
and cons and all this stuff and um and
then there's you guys who were in your
40s and you were like yeah uh you're a
little Ramon yeah yeah you're like oh
Ramone's like throwing out his back
playing pickleball and like you know you
guys were basically some combination of
like let's have fun like let's go
surfing let's play sports like yo seize
the day I don't know how much longer I'm
gonna be able to do all this stuff
constantly like I'm doing it and you
know like I guess like there was like an
element of like
you know yeah business stuff is cool but
like life is a lot cooler than business
um where the 30 year olds and the 20
year olds were like no winning in
business
and like I remember just continually
trying to be like hey guys all right you
guys want to just sit down and just
whiteboard for a minute and it was like
you know just sort of like I was feeling
this urge to do that I feel like you
guys were this urge to like the sun is
out let's go outdoors and like but let's
wear our sunscreen because like we don't
want to die it's like this element of
like I want to live and I don't want to
die that's where you guys were at and
then we hung out with like a
seven-year-old guy and he was just sort
of like
oh you know I want some action I'm bored
I want some action and like you know um
I want to contribute I want to give back
and like that was like a big focus and
like uh you know it's just fun to have
like this energy around me so that was
kind of one observation I had you know
hey is that is that accurate as far as
you read it or am I making stuff up here
yeah it's super accurate uh Ramon and I
were like it's Saturday night and we
have a bunch of entrepreneurs who are
just like trying to sell us on their
business and just like get themselves
excited and meet people and Network
and me and Ramon were like it's nine
o'clock I think it's time to go to bed
and these guys are like no I'll stay up
till 2 A.M let's talk about business
ideas let's start a new business
tomorrow oh my God this guy is selling
mini katanas on the internet through
YouTube and Tick Tock wow
uh so it was a real funny thing and then
you know
you and Ben were like let's talk about
new business ideas here's a new business
idea what do you think what do you think
what do you think oh what about this
what about this and Ramona and I are
like how about we jump in the pool
yeah like just take an ice bath yeah
so it is funny to see these different
seasons of life and
um
yeah I'm trying to kind of adjust this
new season and uh for example now on
Saturdays and Sundays I try not to touch
my laptop at all and be outdoors and
with friends as much as possible well
that is it's hard to make that shift in
that season I mean even at the beginning
of this podcast like I'm gonna buy a
public company and take it to the moon
and then it's like actually I'm gonna
like enjoy life and like you know
whatever you know do family things and
things like that it's
it's hard to even be congruent in a
one-hour podcast with like you know a
kind of like Direction
um so you know I think that's that's
I've observed that amongst many many
people it's like very hard it's very
hard to stay congruent uh I noticed this
about myself like I'll be like oh I love
this content podcast thing this is great
I think I could be the best at this and
then and then I get all this positive
feedback where it's happening and it's
like growing and people like it and then
I'm like yeah but should I start this
business doing this B2B thing and then
it's like wait what happened to the
whole like I want to do this content
thing it's like I don't know like I just
it's hard to be congruent and it's easy
very easy to get distracted and get off
kind of like Mission when you're used to
doing one thing and you know you can
always go back to that well and do it
and there's this new thing that you
think might be the right thing for you
but is different and maybe a little
unfamiliar a little less familiar
I met this guy who uh started a company
called solo stove and sold it
um and it then later went public uh
named Spencer and
um he was like I started this company I
worked really hard I sold it now I made
mega bucks and uh I'm good I'm
financially independent I
um
he doesn't invest in any startups he
doesn't invest in any private Equity
Funds or VC funds he's like when people
are like do you want to invest in this
that the other thing he's like no I'm
good he takes all of his money and puts
it in the stock market in the Vanguard
vo the Vanguard S P 500 Index doesn't
think about it at all and uh he says
that everyone else who is like this is
an entrepreneur starts a company makes
it and then goes back and starts another
company they're only starting another
company because that's the only thing
they know yeah and he's like they just
keep building a new prison for
themselves that's bigger and brighter
but it's still a prison
and uh why would you do that and so I
had this call with him and then for a
week after that I was just like walking
in circles uh like muttering to myself
what am I doing with my life what am I
doing why am I starting new businesses
what is all of this
um so it's really interesting to see
people on the other
end of the spectrum I think I told you
that once when we I remember at uh some
Park in San Francisco you were telling
me about your new thing and it was
working great and I was like I was like
that's I was like that's great and I'm
like uh I admire that you do this with
such ease it's like watching Steph Curry
shoot three pointers like wow you just
could start a business and it just works
like this that that what happened to all
the hard gritty stuff that I feel all
the time like you're just doing it
that's amazing uh but then I also told
you I was like I feel like you're
playing the same level of the video game
again and like you know you kind of beat
this level like shouldn't you just like
go to the next level uh I don't know
what that level even is I don't even
know what that means maybe it's not even
business
um but like you know I said that and I
felt like a real dick afterwards I was
like that was a stupid thing to say I
remember like feeling like you know that
I was like I first felt really bad I was
like that was just kind of like a I
don't know like that probably didn't
feel good to say that or to hear that
and then I was like also like I was like
well do I believe it and like you know
would I want a friend to tell me that if
they felt that about something I was
doing and I was like yeah I think I
would and I was like I think he doesn't
take that stuff seriously so you know
that's no problem
um but you know like
I felt that and I've said I felt seeing
that now in many people the same like
build a prison of your own making and
like you said the only people who win
are the ones who sort of opt out of the
Rat Race and it's really jarring when
you see that and you're like wait what
you're leaving
but you could do we're still here and
they're like yeah we're still here and
they're like yeah it's great
um I'm gonna go wander over here and I'm
like oh my God you can leave this room
like that I didn't know that was
possible it's like it is honestly very
jarring when you meet the like one out
of 100 people in Silicon Valley who do
that
yeah it is uh stunning that people do
that and
um it's so interesting uh when you meet
people who do that and like what they
choose to do with their time like you
were telling me about that Braintree guy
who's like I'm trying to maximize my
life I'm trying to reverse my biological
age yeah yeah and so I change my diet
I've got like a team of doctors uh
nutritionists physical therapists
trainers and I'm reversing my age
um
and that's what he's doing with his time
and energy and money it's super
interesting to hear when people
yeah the thing I've seen I now have this
thought
which is that um my life is actually
limited by my imagination
and uh growing up I always assumed it
was limited by you know money or
resources and now I realize my life is
just limited by my imagination and uh
one of the things that made me do is I'm
trying to hire a chief fund officer my
definition of fun is often like let's
work and let's grind it out I'm trying
to hire somebody who's the exact
opposite of me to
be like no that's lame uh here's like
five more fun things you could be doing
right now go do those instead and I will
literally close my laptop and just go do
one of those five things in response to
that that's amazing did you uh that
thing you just said that my life is
limited by my imagination I think that's
probably I don't know how many minutes
into the podcast here but that's a
that's like a golden nugget right there
like that's something I'm gonna think
about a lot what uh say more about that
like either how you thought of that or
what's an example of that yeah
um you know it's funny because I'm uh
living with my brother right now and the
two of us wake up and we're like it's
Monday morning let's go let's grind it
out let's go let's win the ball game and
um
yesterday we like played paddle tennis
for four hours until our limbs fell off
and that was way more fun that whatever
work we're gonna do today
um
and so I just want somebody to uh
like I don't spend enough I spend all
this time being like actually what's
happened for me is as I've seen more
businesses and gotten older and more
experienced I feel like
this is a little bit of a hyperbole but
I feel like Neo in The Matrix where you
show me a business and I can like see
through it and actually see the
fundamentals of the business and have an
opinion about whether it's a good
business or not or I see opportunities
where I'm like there's a 100 million
dollar business here and it's just a
matter of like doing the work and
executing it and it could be a real
business
um so I spend my so much of my brain
power thinking about that stuff and very
little of my brain power thinking about
how to have fun and like other cool
things that people do in life I spend a
ton of time reading the Wall Street
Journal and talking entrepreneurs but
very little time talking to uh Instagram
influencers or just people who are like
balling out and having a great life
um
and so I just want to spend more of my
time and energy imagining fun things to
do like I love magic I would love to
have a magician show up randomly in my
week
um like while I'm at a restaurant a
magician shows up and is like hey
everybody I got a magic trick for you
and then does a magic trick at the table
I A friend of mine told me that him and
a bunch of guy friends would go to Vegas
every year and one year this guy was in
charge of planning it and he hired
um like five little people in uh tuxedos
to follow them around and then a bunch
of
um like the Brazilian Carnival dancers
to follow them around the whole weekend
and so everywhere they went everyone was
like who are these guys they got into
every Club
they got free drinks they got to all
these people coming up to them and uh
they had a dope weekend as a result and
you know lots of people just go to Vegas
and Like go to the hotel and Gamble and
these guys just through their
imagination had a better way of doing it
yeah amazing um all right this has been
good uh where do people find you you're
you started tweeting so so shout out
your your handle and then we can wrap it
up yeah uh my goal is to get to 100 000
Twitter followers by the end of the year
so I'm gonna be tweeting a bunch more uh
my Twitter handle is my full name uh
s-u-l-e-m-a-n-a-l-i yes all right great
thanks for coming on man you bet thanks
Sean
[Music]
foreign